[Music]
hi I'm Anthony ban here at Google Cloud
next 2023 and I'm here with ning ning
would you like to introduce yourself oh
yeah this is ning here um I'm a product
marketing manager for Google Cloud I'm
working on D AI so ning I would love it
if you could demos demo for us uh duet
ai's Cod completion and uh generation
functionality yeah sure um so here we
have uh a few D demos let me show you
this one it's a d code completion and
code generation demo so here you will
see uh you can using a natural language
comment write a function to generate a
Fibonacci Sequence but just click and
then do AI generate a Blog of code for
you can also add add definition
def
Fibonacci yeah see oh okay give you all
the code like automatically completes
your code and generating the code blogs
for you so love it we have recursion in
there and everything great yeah and
later you will see that um you can
actually work very well for Google Cloud
specific functions cuz we trained uh D
with Google Cloud specific content like
uh documentations code examples uh
Google cloud like best architecture uh
example codes so see here you can ask d
uh with the common write a function to
create a Google Cloud
Storage bucket see what we we're going
to
get yeah so see uh within seconds it can
write you a function a whole function
about uh creating Google Cloud Storage
fet yeah I love it I think like I mean
thinking through uh sort of the
development flow typically if I was
unfamiliar with Google Cloud I would
have to go through read through
documentation understand the functions
right here it looks like it's all
generated for us and I'm assuming you
know this is in the Google style and
best practices so this is fantastic yeah
and even ask him to import uh a Google
Cloud uh storage start yeah keep
going um yeah I love seeing kind of the
range of um problems that it can solve
right like Fibonacci is like a very
famous toy problem and shows like sort
of duet ai's ability to handle some
complexity but even looking at this like
this is something that I'll do way more
than trying to generate Fibonacci
numbers right is like for users like
this type of functions is very very
commonly used and D can save you a lot
of time just writing these kind of ball
PR Cod well thank you so much ning this
was awesome really appreciate the time
and enjoy the rest of the conference
yeah you're
welcome